welcome back to the Rich Eisen show and
I am thrilled to introduce the man to my
right I mean the credits on this man's
film and television ography can fill up
the entire hour taxi One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest get shorty currently It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia so on and
so forth now the new Jumanji film
Jumanji the next level in theaters near
you
coming up this very weekend good to see
you Danica people very much rich it's
very nice to be I am pleased to have you
here sir yeah
so where do it so you're are you're
originally from New Jersey rapport New
Jersey sure
it's like midway between Atlantic City
and the in the big city the Big Apple
kind of the home of Bruce Springsteen
right - born and free hole which is
inland a little bit but he came to
Asbury where he honed his craft and
became very famous at The Stone Pony and
in the early days and you ever see him
there oh no I never saw him and I had
gone out a couple couple of years before
he really landed and started taking off
but I was a big fan of his work and also
from the very beginning because he was a
ho you know local boy a hometown guy and
yeah and and I did get a kick out of him
calling his first album greetings from
Asbury Park right I actually did a
Saturday Night Live once where I said
this story and on I said well he
couldn't he was born in freehold New
Jersey yeah he couldn't call his first
albums greeting from free old exactly
when when did you do that SNL when was
that Wow
taxi got canceled by ABC after the first
five seasons uh-huh and we were all
devastated because the show was doing
great amazing and we didn't know why
right and we were a family
and
that's the that's Lauren Michael said
let's do a a show about you know taxi
getting cancelled
it'll be we bring I brought that year
everyone won Emmys we won all kinds of
you statues right stuff and we all
brought them on I brought the whole cast
on the show onto a condom my monologue
and and then very very soon after or
maybe even before that Brandon Tartikoff
who was at ABC who at NBC right
he brought the show over for the final
we did a final season the fifth season
so that you know I
the mechanics works that the studio pays
for the for the shortfall
sorry beginning and then when this movie
starts making money that they they start
making their money I'm trying to I'm
trying to match up the timeframes here
so was Bill Murray a cast member Murray
gone John Belushi gone gone right there
was still you know Dana Carvey there was
Betty Murphy there was there was there
were there was still amazing amazing
comic cast members that were right just
wonderful to work with you know yeah
John loved it yeah shut me and all right
you know things like that we did some
crazy crazy things and and so we did
that show and and then we were brought
on to NBC for that final year which
really put it over the top for everybody
Danny DeVito here on the Rich Eisen show
so growing up in in Asbury Park did so
were you like a Yankee fan did you did
you dodge Mike my father was born in
Brooklyn that's born in New Jersey
breath somehow he was a Brooklyn Dodger
fan when the abbot's field was there and
the whole thing he'd take me to the tape
to me to Ebbets Field and we would watch
the Dodgers no matter what when they
were on TV my mother which made a really
interesting house
I was a Yankee fan at that time if you
remember that was like that's a head and
head
oh sure you know that was like forget
about it the Yankees won everything that
all the dough right they they they they
got the players and you know and my
father was like we were in the junior
Gilliam and you know and we were dead
Pee Wee Reese and short Duke Snider Duke
Snider and we had Roy Campanella now Roy
Campanella Yeah right I'm an
italian-american family my father would
not let us go by the TV if an Italian
was on television whether they were
singing with Rufus Connie Francis or
whether it was hey you know Tony Bennett
or Mel Torme when Roy Campanella was up
to bat
we had to sit there and watch so I mean
Lasorda if your dad ever watched a
Lasorda like this my father Thomas yeah
why I don't know just this crazy guy in
fact that's Danny DeVito here on the
Rich Eisen show alright let's talk about
Jumanji the next level yes film
wonderful now I mean I don't want to
give away too much but we did see in the
trailer when Dwayne Johnson was talking
the way in which he was talking gay and
now he's seeing you are in this film the
most of people know the premise of the
is people get sucked into the video yes
and I happen to be in the house Danny
Glover's in the house yes Wow the thing
sucks us in yes and and we have avatars
when we get to the we get to the
wherever yes these crazy places right
and they're all my wild ice things snow
is this ostriches is that this mandrels
attacking anyway they have to run after
away from them but they are running away
from them as us as you so they become us
you know Dwayne has to go what do we in
Florida yes to do this so how would you
how would you rate his doing a great job
he did a great job he mailed me I was
the coach but he didn't listen how did
you coach him on out at all you know I
told like I'm talking to you right you
want to do it
sure you want to try it well I mean I'm
from Staten Island with also matter I
know that against you so what so what so
what what - listen my desk this is all
this stuff
all this on my desk hey you hey what's
all this on my desk
hey you Charlie come over here Charlie
come over here see how a my la for a
while but you know yeah it's a
contaminating place from Brooklyn and
Staten I know every now and then if you
cut me off a trafficker will come out
you know really having a man they don't
care just keep going yeah it's funny to
again see Dwayne Johnson doing does a
great job with the Jack Black very funny
Kevin Hart Danny Glover is like the
sweetest man in the world you know all
these all these folks that were in the
movie before and and Aquafina a norm
place she was a really great the thing
is that what Dwayne would watch me all
the time so it was like it was like I
thought in beginning I said man this
guy's interested in me but then I got it
he was watching me it's over I get a cup
of coffee
he'd walk over get a cup of coffee no
kidding he's really a method actor okay
yeah by the way if the movie does really
well I'm gonna charge you more yeah you
don't get the back end Danny but you
know you don't need to tell me you got
me to tell you how you do your business
I know so I saw that you are you crashed
a wedding with him we amazing
moaning the movie was really sweet we
did the three or four days in Cabo which
was really amazing Brian Cabo San Lucas
if you ever get a chance to go it's
beautiful place and we had like four or
five days of promotion of the movie and
coincidentally we overlapped one day
with a wedding that was already planned
there hmm and so the night that they
were gonna have their drinks or whatever
they were gonna do before the wedding
the wedding was on Saturday that night
we was still doing press so we still had
all of our stuff there cameras this that
and the other thing so it was a little
inconvenience for the bride and groom
but they they were cool about I think
it's right yeah and then as a little
icing on the cake when they had their
wedding and it was all said it was
really beautiful they had all the
there's 70 80 people there and the kids
were there and there the whole thing and
Dwayne and I came out of the kitchen
singing unforgettable unforgettable
that's what you are you know to the
bride and Wayne I think they'd all right
the bride at our the husband had a heart
attack had to be taken to the hospital
well I saw the advice you gave the
couple in the video on how to have a
successful man yeah go get a big house
so you you don't have to bump into each
other did you get that from the roses
all right and the few minutes I have
left with you here Danny DeVito again
Jumanji the next level in theaters
coming up on this very Friday I have
some facts taken from stories that have
been written about you and we want to
make sure that the area the true or
false in celebrity true or false if you
know me okay go for it hit it my filter
to fire here we go
and interestingly enough we begin with a
Nicholson conversation here during the
filming of Batman Returns true or false
you remained in character as the penguin
between takes yes yes I did so did that
freak anybody out
I definitely did not basically once you
get into the suit and you're in there
for three hours doing it yeah the only
time I broke was at lunch and what we do
you had a little cart that would take me
from the set mm-hmm a little wagon like
a circus wagon take me over to my
trailer where I had a tent set up and
the tables outside and I had a friend of
mine it was a really good cook
Vincent's Kiev le who was already it was
in the movie he he would cook some
amazing meal and then sometimes I had my
flippers on and they were glued on so
they'd have to feed me this wash mouth
Weissach I'd squirt in yes so it's just
like it's spirulina and mouthwash and
something landed too and I squirted it
in before I go and then the director
would say action and I go and is it true
that is it true that Nicholson told you
to do the role because Nicholson was so
well compensated from the first Batman
movie yeah he said no he you know wasn't
yeah pretty much
he said Tim was the man timber I said I
loved you know I loved you saw the
movies price and so Tim asked me to be
in the part it's a great part it's
operatic it's like everything that an
actor would want that part is written
like Golder so tragic you know a tragic
a bird who cannot fly the
duality of the other characters sorry
you're playing all those things and to
have that you know all that fun stuff to
be to be doing you you wouldn't want to
pass that one all right next one is it
true that you were considered for the
role of George Costanza and Seinfeld is
that true no that is all they copied me
in George Costanza okay they said they
had George Costanza right they had
Kramer Kramer was like Reverend Jim
Ignatowski Yeah right
Jerry was kind of like yeah every good
right you say the word Rieger like that
this brings back an amazing memories
like that what are you doing fantastic
is it true you like to have a trampoline
in your dressing I do okay I do because
it what a trampoline does is think it
takes all the muscles in your body and
it it gives them a workout okay so if
you bounce on a trampoline I do it
before I go on I do it before I you know
I do sometimes just during the day it's
a it's a real muscle
it's like dynamic tension uh-huh but
only you're doing it like on a
trampoline did you do it in the penguin
outfit I didn't know I did it before I
put the penguin outfit on okay I did it
when I did Broadway when I do
any-any when I did the price when I do
Sonny I do I trampoline it's good it's
good for you you should try trampoline
before you you know what stick it over
in the corner
[Applause]
what do you been doing this week what's
happening I wish you know if we'd known
that I would have passed that
information along to the Commissioner
before you were in the suite for the
Super Bowl though this year in in
Atlanta you could have been trampolining
during the Rams and Patriots Super Bowl
game that was like being in a waxworks
I mean all these guys we just like are
totally billionaires sitting in rows
ball these all Justin I'm Bali but then
I'm sitting in the back of well using a
whole row a ball heads competing with
the lights you can hardly see this I
don't like watching from the booth once
in a while the only thing bad about
going in the stands you got to do
autographs and selfies which I don't
mind okay I like it
right but 3,000 of them I mind the thing
up in the up in the booth you know they
got the food and everything yeah and you
stay away from those guys right it's
just you just have to sit behind Rupert
Murdoch talk identify him right away and
you go watch Chris I'm telling ya that's
a fact that happened at this year's Rams
Patriots Super Bowl alright last one for
you while you were in acting school in
New York City your roommate was Michael
Douglas
this is a half-truth okay okay um I was
already out of acting school I've been
doing off-broadway off-off-broadway some
stocks on it's the Children's Theater
and stuff like that we shared a place on
89th Street he was doing the streets of
San Francisco doing stuff in
off-broadway off looking for work right
so it was a good marriage we Kris like
we we we weren't in the apartment quite
a lot like it was only several parts
that were you know where we were thrust
together in 89th Street and those were
the things that I was talking about
about being a good marriage
we were great I mean you know we've
decided right away who was the top and
who was the bottom we Michael like doing
laundry okay that's good you know
folding ah the best ah who did the
cooking up me okay course it was you
what's the best thing you cook what's
the best thing I cook everything really
really good my guy over there from New
Jersey Mike del two folks a mean baked
ziti yeah yeah can you do you got well
no I have a good have a good baked ziti
okay well all Italian guys from at least
you know you you you're Italian guy he
had a mother of course so your mom Oney
come ammonia's he hangs around his
mother all the time and whenever she's
in the kitchen
we became memo knees because first of
all we wanted a dunk yeah yeah alright
yeah and she's gonna get out of here and
you walk over when she's not looking and
you take the Cooley pond the cooling
pond is it's okay okay it's a little
Italian bread the two ends are the ass
of the bread you take the end and you go
over and you sneak over to the sauce you
think it in you know hide the forks and
the fourth oh yeah Danny DeVito here on
the Rich Eisen show this has been an
absolute pleasure
let's well thanks again please come back
and we'll talk some more go see Jumanji
Jumanji the next level integers near you
on on this very Friday December the 13th
that's right and also next time you come
we'll have a trampoline for you okay
know now that we know do the [ __ ] yeah
I didn't get that rider I'll get that in
the right this time
Danny DeVito right here on the Rich
Eisen show again check out Jumanji the
next level in theatres new you this
Friday for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app